[Musik]
und ich schon wi diese Kamera übrigens
das neue iPhone
15 das erste Mal dass ich das sehe ich
habe es mir auch geholt also mein noch
nicht da aber halt bei mir war ich halt
damit beruflich Filme du spielst Poker
damit Poker ja vor zi dreogs habe ich
gesagt dass ich mich auf den Herbst
freue ich nehm es zurück ich habe total
vergessen dass ja auch dieses pissige
Nieselwetter mit dazu
kommt ich habe noch niemanden gefunden
der schneller Fahrad fährt als ich in
der
Innenstadt wir fahren beide locker
40° sehr
gut unser Hotel du gottloser nach meinem
morgendlichen Rudern mit vierat und dem
darauffolgenden Krafttraining mit Mo
habe ich mich dann dazu entschlossen
noch eine kleine Runde joggen zu gehen
und dafür natürlich nur für euch auch
extra cool hier mein Handy H ellt um
mich dabei so episch wie möglich zu
filmen
wow Ex versucht cool zu gucken beim Jog
schon fast 20 km hinter mir ich bin so
tot das ist übgens der dümpel von Köln a
unser einziger See 20 cm tief voll mit
Scheiße gefühlt seitdem ich in Köln
wohne und das S mittlerweile knapp 9
Jahre ist da eine Baustelle
als wenn die mal wieder was bauen dann
abreißen wieder neub bauen D wieder
abreißen ich weiß nicht was S da
machen wenn ich joggen lauf ich auch
immer durch die Innenstadt ich fin total
affig wenn man sagt man läuft durch den
Wald das ist total langweilig sieh nur
Blätter und wenn man durch Innenstadt
läuft hat man immer Leute be ein rum die
man irgendwie beeindrucken will damit
man irgendwie Ticken schneller läuft ist
ein bisschen peinlich aber na ja ich bin
übgens glaub ich der einzige Mensch der
seine Einkaufsliste nicht sortiert von
wegen erst die Tiefkühlprodukte dann
dies dann das sondern immer einfach
alles
aufschreiben resultiert dann darin dass
ich meistens Zickzack durch den ganzen
Laden laufen alle denken ich bin der
letzte Idiot hab mein Leben nicht im
Griff aber es wird gesund gekocht
Haferflocken Banane ich kann
[Musik]
kotzen
Alter ich h ich f tatsächlich wieder zu
Francesco ich se schon alle Kommentare
kommen ich bin der Ansicht rote Ampel
Option sein sollten ich fin soll
generell so ein paar neue Regeln geben
was das ampelgame angeht in Deutschland
man bräuchte diese Zahlen wie Ausland
dass die so runterzählen damit ich weiß
wenn die Ampel grün ist auf Entfernung
wie schnell muss ich fahren dann steht
17 Sekunden
grün leise das sollte es geben dann
sollte es auch noch die Möglichkeit
geben dass man immer über Rot gehen darf
wenn halt keine Autos in der Nähe sind
so wie so ein zebastreifen und das ganze
aber nicht gilt wenn Kinder in der Nähe
sind wenn Kinder da irgendwie stehen
darf man nicht über Rot
gehen vielleicht würde ich auch deutlich
komplizierter machen wenn ich Kanzler wä
aber W schon schit ich Kanzler Luca
Kanzler
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Laser eine Sache die ich in Köln nicht
verstehen werde sind diese
Doppeldeckerbusse warum macht man
das seid in Köln nicht in London oder
tok Alter was gibt's hier zu sehen außer
den Dom und
mich willst du dein Instagram Puschen ja
okay also ich sag das eigentlich ungern
aber ich heiß da Laser Luca okay alle
Folgen frco hat so viel abgeschnitten
ich wollte das aber auch ein mal so ein
bisschen cleaneren Look ah ich weiß
nicht F gerade freihändig das ist extrem
schwierig bei so Rennrädern alle unter
euch die Rennradfahrer s wissen das also
wahrscheinlich niemand in einem meiner
letzten Vlogs habe ich gesagt dass ich
früher da oben gewohnt habe da oben habe
ich früher gewohnt und unter dem Vlog
haben mich extrem viele Leute gefragt ob
ich noch Fotos aus dieser Wohnung habe
weil das halt eine einzimmer Wohnung war
22 madr direkt am zöbicherplatz also ein
ziemliches saufittel hier in Köln so
studentenmäßig und ich habe ein bisschen
recherchiert und habe dieses Foto
gefunden da sitze ich gerade quasi mein
Wohnzimmer ich hat halt nur ein Zimmer
und das hier ist so Panoramabild da hat
man quasi die ganze Wohnung gesehen das
sieht ein bisschen größer aus als 22 qu
aber es war wirklich sehr sehr klein
also bitte an alle die gefragt
[Musik]
haben wenn du könntest in welches
Zeitalter würdest du reisen zurück oder
nach ganz vorne sind die wichtigen
Themen für die Umwelt CO2
freundlich
Freunde ja alle unter euch die heute
schon auf tiktok unterwegs waren wissen
denke ich worum es geht denn dort ging
heute dieses videoviral julenko schießt
gegen laserla das bin ich wir schauen
uns den Braten mal
an me zu
[Musik]
Laser früher sehr viele Videos gedreht
wo er auch sehr krich und gesprochen hat
sage ich mal und auch einfach so so
unberechtigte Kritik sage ich
mal
unberechtigte
Kritik
wapb ist das deutsche Youtube Video was
innerhalb der ersten 24 Stunden nach
Upload die meisten dislikes aller Zeiten
gesammelt
hat keine einzige Kritik zu diesem Song
ist berechtigt noch so ganz viel Klicks
auf de Nacken gesetzt wisst ihr so als
es dam mit dem Song war und sowas so so
20 Videos hintereinander so und so ein
ob sol lang es noch Klicks gibt mache
ich weiter das waren tatsächlich keine
20 Videos sondern
zwei mag ich nicht sowas warum kommst
jetzt nach se Jahren damit an morgen
mache ich ein Video gegen Simon unge
weil er vor 8 Jahren bei mega Projekt
TNT gezündet
hat dann habe ichmer im Kino getroffen
oder so wir haben uns nie im Kino
getroffen Bro ich weiß nicht was in
deiner Haferflocken Müsli kackschale da
drin ist die dich auch die ganze Zeit
irgendwie so zum Wackeln bringt aber ich
will davon vielleicht bisschen weniger
essen Party habe ich mal getroffen Dach
komm ich rede trotzdem mit dir
aber ja war dann irgendwie nicht viel
Gespräch fand ich dann noch eher so ein
bisschen feige muss ich sagen erch
schönen Happen nehmen ne die Party gab's
im Gegensatz zur kinosituation
tatsächlich das war nämlich die
Universal Party die hat vor 6 Jahren im
Rahmen der vide stattgefunden und ich
war dort mit ein paar Freunden und unter
anderem auch Lukas rieeger und wir sind
dann vom Außenbereich in den
Innenbereich gegangen weil dort drinen
halt die Theke war und wir Getränke für
unsere Freunde draußen holen wollten auf
dem Weg nach drinen haben wir dann
julienko und Bibi getroffen haben uns
halt nur kurz unterhalten war einmal
kurz smallt vielleicht Z 10 20 Sekunden
und dann sind wir Hal weiter zur Bar
gegangen ich weiß nicht was daran feige
sein
sollte
wir können das ganze ja bei einem
Boxkampf
[Applaus]
klären Luca sag mal wur du nicht vor di
Wochen für ein Boxkampf angefragt ja
wurde ich gegen wen sollst du da denn
kämpfen gegen julienko und wurden dir
dafür nicht sogar 250 000 € Angeboten ja
und hast du dem ganzen
zugestimmt ich habe es abgelehnt warum
weil ich generell alle wirklichen TV
influencer Livestream riesigen Show
Events ablehne weil ich das einfach
irgendwie nicht mag aber sag mal kann es
dann nicht eventuell sein dass julienko
denkt du wärst dabei und er deswegen
jetzt einen Fake beef im tiktok
Livestream anfängt damit man den Fight
richtig gut promoten
kann spaß beiseite Freunde ich
möchteulen natürlich nicht irgendwas
unterstellen ja die Anfrage für den
Boxkampf gegen ihn im Februar gab es
tatsächlich die habe ich aber wie
bereits gesagt direkt abgelehnt weil ich
bin einfach kein Fan von so riesigen
influencer Livestream Show Events ich
finde es immer so ein bisschen affig
würde mich dabei glaube ich einfach
nicht wohlfühlen deswegen habe ich es
halt direkt abgesagt ich kann mir auch
nicht vorstellen dass julenko das jetzt
nicht mitbekommen hat und dachte er
kämpft jetzt gegen mich im Februar und
will jetzt ein fakebeef anfangen so ihr
kennt meine jokes das war offensichtlich
humorvoll gemeint vielleicht hat er
einfach wirklich ein Livestream gemacht
und dachte sich halt nur so oh da steht
laserla ich sag mal kurz meine Meinung
so oder so finde ich dann aber auch
völlig okay dass ich dazu meine Meinung
einfach auch kurz sage hier am Ende von
dem Vlog ich dazu jetzt auch nicht
irgendwie so ein riesen tiktok beef
anfangen oder so um Gottes Willen das
nicht meine Welt aber ich finde wenn da
Halbwahrheiten irgendwie verbreitet
werden kann ich das auch ganz kurz
klarstellen deswegen giulienko ich
reichtte meine
Hand ist ein bisschen schwitzig so oder
so möchte ich trotzdem noch mal ganz
kurz das sagen was ich eigentlich in
jeder reaction auch dazu sage und zwar
dass keine Kommentare von mir in
irendeiner Weise böse gemeint sind oder
sich gegen die Person hinter der
gespielten Rolle oder dem Content
richten das ist mir ganz ganz wichtig
das habe ich auch in den ganzen Dom
reactions gesagt und beispielsweise ist
es auch so bei Tanzverbot oder kuchenv
sind ja auch Personen die mit ihrem
Content oft
anecken wo ich auch nicht komplett
konform mit dem gehe was sie teilweise
hochladen oder von sich geben mich aber
mit beiden eigentlich in echt immer als
ich sie gesehen habe sehr gut verstanden
habe und ich finde das ist auch einfach
wichtig dass man das einfach
differenziert betrachtet und das ganze
voneinander trennt diese Aussage mit
Klicks auf Nacken
das finde ich mal so ein bisschen
schwierig weil ich meine ihr seid halt
einfach damals die größten Youtuber in
Deutschland gewesen und habt auch echt
bisschen Scheiße gebaut in der ein oder
Situation natürlich macht man da Content
zu das habe aber auch nicht nur ich
gemacht sondern noch ganz viele andere
ich meine Julian du hast do selber eine
Videoidee von mir mal kopiert die
Videoidee habe ich bei Luca entdeckt
also nicht wundern der das glaub ich
gemacht dass er Leute angerufen hat und
damals war meine Reaktion darauf einfach
einen netten Kommentar unter euer Video
zu schreiben und jetzt nicht irgendwie
zu sagen Klicks auf Nacken machen mag
ich nicht Blabla Youtube dicker im
Endeffekt sind wir alle eine Familie
jedoch würde ich an der Stelle den
heutigen Blog jetzt auch beenden
ich sehe schon wieder die ganzen
Kommentare von wegen e ihr seid
erwachsene Männer ihr könnt das doch
auch privat klären ich
weißenko wenn du vor 6 Jahren Probleme
meinen Videos hattest hättest du mir
auch schreiben können dann hätte ich
damit aufgehört aber fragt euch doch mal
selbst Freunde wenn über euch im
Internet geredet wird und das
hundertausende Leute sehen da möchtet
ihr doch glaube ich auch was dazu sagen
in diesem Sinne wir haben uns alle lieb
julienko und ich Kuscheln und Knuddeln
uns bald ganz ganz ganz ganz doll und
ich jetzt scheißen